what do you think is the reason we are losing
members our members and and what is your solution
john 12 well the bible has a solution i don't
have one john 12 32 and i if i be lifted up from
the earth will draw all men unto me the first
application of that verse is crucifixion he was
lifted up on the cross it also means lift him up
when you preach lift up truth will draw people to
christ in the great controversy page 509 paragraph
one ella white writes conformity to worldly custom
never convert converts the church to the world it
never converts the world to christ let me say that
again conformity to worldly custom converts the
church to the world it never converts the world
to christ when you mingle the things of god with
the secular things you weaken the power of the
message and people drift are you following
me god called the israelites to be different
and they said to samuel in 1st samuel chapter 8
make us a king to judge us like the other nations
when you're called to be different and you act as
though you want to be like everybody else it is an
insult to god you are desiring a path contrary
to the one for which god brought you into
existence to be different and so we lose
members because we drift from the truth
i was conducting an evangelistic
series in a certain church in canada
and i told them we meet every night for three
weeks and they said every night so there's little
opposition to that so the pastor said come and
talk to the member so i flew to that city where it
was and sat down and met with them and they gave
me all kinds of reasons why they can't come every
night i said to one when can you come tuesday
night well you come on tuesday night when can
you come wednesday when you come on wednesday but
i can't shut down the meeting because you cannot
come on the thursday so we have the meeting and
the past of that meeting told me in the third week
of all the meetings they have had in the past the
average attendance at night was about 30 people
we averaged 160 people because all i did was to do
what gave them thus saith the lord that's no joke
there's god listening to me i was called to do an
evangelistic series in minneapolis and one night
the executive secretary or ministerial director
of the conference came and he saw the people so he
asked the local pastor how do you get 200 people
in a church on a tuesday night and the pastor said
listen to me
they're all kind of gimmicks
churches use to so-called hold people
holding someone in a church building
is not holding the person in christ
there are two different things you can hold
someone in the building is the person in christ
only this this keeps a person in christ in all my
travels i've observed this attracts old and young
and i get tech so all the
time young people telling me
they want to walk with god god is
my witness young people all the time
pastors have sinned i want to get
close to god and i give them this
this
you